perché a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
queste novità sono famiglie oggi sono
tornati su un episodio un po particolare
una reaction una reaction è un po che
non facevo reaction ma le migliori che
ho fatto su youtubers italiani secondo
me si riferiscono a sotto major che sono
e che questo ragazzo che fa animazioni
discutibili ma c'è nel senso che fa
delle robe strane che non saprei
spiegare però non so se vi ricordate
avevo fatto reaction alla vera la vera
storia di lorenzo studi gara incredibile
oggi abbiamo fa vj versus giva la
vendetta di pietro già solo per
inventarsi un nome del genere meriti
l'oscar però andiamo avanti ragazzi mi
piacete l'omesso mettetelo anche voi a
questo video per cortesia io l'ho visto
niente niente non ho visto niente però
ho notato già la parte minuto zero
secondi 0 c'è la partenza che merita già
l'oscar perché privo cioè la sedia da
gaming che non ho mai avuto però vabbè
puntualizziamo alcune cose allora
analizziamo le cose perché l'abbiamo la
foto di gerry scotti che c'è io non so
come mai non ho una foto di adesso
mettiamo la foto digerisco giacomo
poretti ovviamente perché giacomino
nelle foto ha un senso giacomo vieni a
casa mia facciamo un video insieme per
cortesia prove e secondo me è meglio che
cominciamo con il video ragazzi partiamo
era una bella giornata il sole risplende
va oltre la finestra
va bene francesco sole che interpreta il
sole ok
insomma una di quelle giornate in cui
fai un sospiro
guardi fuori e dc ei oggi è davvero una
bella giornata
tutto stava procedendo per il meglio
quando poi arrivò pietro ma perché
ridete tra l'altro vorrei puntualizzare
che la voce che lui fa di pietro è
veramente simile se uno va in secondo
lui entra in this thing che parla con me
perché dobbiamo registrare la voce è
uguale uguale incredibile
dai non è che per far ridere basta dire
la parola pietro per noel effetti pietro
fa sempre di meno
vabbè ero venuto per scusarmi per quello
che ho fatto ma se è così me ne vado ma
andiamo indietro di due giorni ma cosa
sta succedendo
ma cos'è il ore ho noleggiato fermi
cos'è successo nell'arco di cinque sei
gol di jeda abbiamo avuto una
conversazione impossibile due giorni
prima bove partenza così voi scherzate
ma io sta canzone l'ho ascoltata
veramente così sdraiato sulla sedia per
giorni quindi incredibile però avanti
complimenti per i peli posto film
preferito dirty dancing lo guardiamo da
te lo zio non posso delle questioni da
risolvere
avrò mai comprato del latte della stessa
bocca due volte a tramite va a fifa loro
bellico
sì il latte della stessa anche due volte
sì perché se compri leva le cose celle l
bottiglie in stock è sicuramente la
vacca avrà fatto più bottiglie quindi
sicuro sicuro mentre per quanto riguarda
da voi deva sia perché non dovrebbe aver
l'omelia perché non sono nati da
interessante perché lo cerca credo di sì
avevano anche un gatto a consumare
propria nuova mi ha attaccato il
telefono in mangia votato ragazzi a
perché pietro e nella casa di spongebob
a per chi è pure la pagherà avrò la mia
vendetta
quanto è vero che mi chiamo pietro dai
ragazzi ma qual è il vostro problema e
così mi raccomando dottor pivelli cloni
ok benessere potrò cornelius bank art of
tennessee ok dottor house
devo fargliela pagare ha rifiutato berti
dancing con me non posso perdonarlo
devo vendicarmi lo sostituirò come amico
e anche come youtuber e conquisterò il
piano
beh le mutande mi sorprende quanto sia
accurato totò cornelius van cut off
perché c'ha la parrucca che è veramente
voluminosa quanto quella vera cioè io vi
assicuro che veramente così la barocca i
kart of kong anni avanti si vuole
conquistare il pianeta prenda un numero
e si faccia la fila come tutti questa
arriva giù nel posto allora tra tori
c'era 70 salvini ignasi gironi ricette
attentamente gesto molto importante
diceva mia nonna candese ricetta opera
essere perfetta
abbiamo tuttavia nonna diceva che bande
e opera essere perfetta non seguire i
cento al contrario e credenti se dottore
tutti ingredienti richiesti sono stati
acquistati li hai presi prodotti dalla
lista che ti ho lasciato sul tavolo
certo mister white quella non è la roba
che ti ho detto di prendere che li stai
preso quella che era sul tavolo ma
aspetta ma questo vuol dire che mamma
non mi sento tanto bene ma no dai
geniale sta roba e secondo fi dovere
fare più grande invenzione conto ma tin
carotene cartofer festa eccezionale mio
non avere pensa te mia più grande
creazione o mio dio e le molecole al
cepu portare i suoi frutti
la clonazione che vesto eccezionale il
dottore qui nelle partenze c'è scritto
che dovevano essere utilizzati solo
ingredienti senza olio di palma
perché ci potrebbero essere delle
conseguenze a baggianate olio di palma
mai fare male a nessuno
ma cos'è fermi fermi fermi aiuto cosa
sto vedendo e geniale star voglio
comprarmi una tuta di vegeta bellissimo
spaventosa avendo l'ho trovata ragazzi
ma non credo che sia come quella che ho
visto però va bene vai avanti comunque
venire fare sel vi ricordo che votro
fallissero dal bellissimo al self i
complimenti nazione nome che ricordi
originale fa vige tale nome scegliere
essere indeciso
all ma ci sono ti chiamerò fabrizio
tante voci ma cosa sto vedendo ragazzi
vi prego loro problemi con lingua lis
troupe si è vista il mondo così mi
aspetta aspetta ma da chi parte del
corpo e l'ha tirata fuori quell'arma poi
è diventare nuovo amico di pietro
impossessarsi del canale youtube di
farli j
e poi conquistare il mondo capito
non puoi usare quest'arma siamo su un
video su internet è questo e non è
family friendly quindi l'arma ovviamente
non è vera ed è inutilizzabile
questa cosa pietro l'avrebbe detta sul
serio la fei e imbarazzante quanto si
assimila pietro vabbè ci sei cascato a
noi cosa ce ne frega dei primi li
friendly preparati ad essere
disintegrato beh si sta anche impegnando
ovunque bene amiche pietre sono problemi
suoi riscrivendoli che li vediamo al
prossimo video morire e stavo dicendo
preparati a morire ho fatto creare
questo clone che prenderà il tema è
uguale a me o duale ma ma ma sei
bellissimo anche plus è davvero
bellissimo ecco miley cieco ma che
finale ma che finale tra l'altro lui non
si è per niente accorto nel fatto che
dietro c'è una immagine della monna lisa
con la sua faccia cioè orribile va bene
tranne pietro non dire di no l'amico
aspetto non dire di no a un amico che ti
invita a guardare due arti dancing e la
morale della storia ragazzi però vorrei
spezzare una lancia a favore di pietro
dirty dancing proprio non l'ho mai visto
proprio quindi non ho intenzioni
guardarlo a prescindere quindi non
cambia film potrei anche venire
tagliati peli che sul petto amico mio io
vorrei vedere la reazione di pietro sta
roba cioè se pietro
innanzitutto schiro nei commenti cosa ne
pensi se ci sei amiche timi se ti sei
piaciuto più tu o più la monna lisa
dietro permetti una giornalista
veramente un colpo da maestro prova beh
se volete l'apparizione di favi getta in
tutto questo mi vestirò da veggente ha
comunque sotto ma york io non so cosa ti
mangi
ma lo voglio anche io signori questa era
la riesce una pa vj versus g vaff
io non so non so che dire vi ringrazio
per avere questa fantasia perché ogni
volta non so neanche come reagire però
complimenti e direi che non incide al
prossimo video se pietro non mi ruba il
canale o cose del genere iscrivetevi
lasciato mi piace la campanellina lo
vede schiacciare e noi ci vediamo a
questo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]